[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef who's
helped put Filipino food on the nation's
menu born in New York to a family from
the Dominican Republic
Miguel Trinidad started working in the
hospitality industry as a delivery boy
but found his way into the kitchen and
went on to culinary school and jobs as
an executive chef that's when he met
Nicole Fonseca Filipino native and on a
backpacking trip through her homeland
fell for its multicultural cuisine they
went on to open two critically acclaimed
restaurants Maharlika and jeepney and
last year they published I am a Filipino
named one of 20:18 best cookbooks by the
New York Times and other publications
chef Miguel Trinidad welcome to the dish
thank you so much for having us what a
spectacular table tell us what's here
we'll start over a dead end and we
brought a variety of dishes lumpia being
the crispy spring roll type of followed
by Suman which is a rice cake that's
been wrapped in banana leaves and
steamed you have the oxtail here you
have the benka adobo dobe was a national
dish and this one was made with pork and
chicken
Okoye which is a shrimp fritter and of
course you need a little something sweet
you have this flan you are first cuz I
don't think I've ever met a chef who's
actually been born in New York City
taxi yes I was born in New York City
taxicab mom broke water in the elevator
hopped in a cab and it was speeding
towards the hospital pulled over by the
cops they saw what was happening gave us
an escort to the hospital I was out
before we even this this this incredible
way that you bring about food to the
palate being born in New York City it's
like this it's such a diversity of
cultures here when I got involved with
Filipino food it was just a burst of
flavor it was something that I had never
had before I didn't know much about it
and meeting Nicole I was introduced to
the food and really dove into it to find
out more about the culture and all the
similarities between Filipino food and
Dominican food it wasn't until you were
33 then you ended up going to culinary
school you had you had little adventures
in commercial photography and the
dot-coms mm-hmm so so what was the delay
you know I was involved in the content
in the hospitality industry so
when I was 17 as a delivery boy I've
worked so many different facets of it
and I was involved in catering so I
started my own company and happened chef
didn't show up to work one day and I
jumped in the kitchen now I had to do it
and you know from there I said let me go
to school and see what this is all about
it was Nicole pancetta who hired you at
your first real job of the soul food
place yes that was my first interview
out of culinary school yeah Nicole was
the person who gave me my first
interview before I went in front of chef
right and we met at the Soho restaurant
and as we developed a friendship you
know I got to know her better and I saw
her crying one day in the corner I said
what's going on she's like I want to
open up a Filipino place but there
aren't Filipino chef to believe it will
ever be accepted mainstream really I'd
be very little about Filipino food I
said let me be your puppet alright so so
well why did you take that challenge it
was something of you it's something that
hasn't been done in New York there were
Filipino restaurants and Queens and
Jersey yeah but the vision that she had
was different than anything else that we
had seen mm-hm and for me was exciting
I'm doing something new you know getting
out of culinary school I thought I was
gonna cook Italian food I ended up doing
Filipino food we something that I didn't
know much about and I could learn and be
creative with and you really immerse
yourself in the culture though to make
this like it is your own I dove into the
culture we backpacked through the
Philippines for three and a half months
to really learn we started at the most
northern point and worked our way south
and just the way the cuisine changed
from region to region was amazing and
imagine it's like being a kid at FAO
Schwarz this was my playground this was
my toys I can learn from all these
different people and bring it back to
the United States and we opened up
maharloka first and introduced Filipino
food to binky's village ah well if you
could as we enjoy this brilliant meal
sign the dish and tell us there you
could have this with anyone who would it
be you know that's a loaded question
it always is because you think about all
the people that you would want to sit at
a table with I would love to sit with
that long either yeah it's a godfather
of you
molecular gastronomy I would love to
just pick his brain it's like how did
you come up with this no no what a feast
it really is a feast we thank you so
much Miguel and chef Miguel Trinidad has
a lot more to teach us if you like to
know more about him head to our website
at CBS this morning dot-com